jetzt geht es auch in der luftfahrt
schlag auf schlag die nasa hat das
design eines überschallflugzeuges
vorgestellt mit dem passagiere in drei
stunden von europa in die usa fliegen
können und ein weiterer hersteller boom
hat gerade 21 millionen eingesammelt um
einen prototypen fliegen zu lassen und
auch hier geht es ganz schnell schlag
auf schlag also passagierflüge mit
überschall endlich wieder ist es möglich
jetzt ein klick zum 26 herzlich
willkommen
dass man das karriereende des rtl-
chefredakteur dieser level i sich mit
einem überschall jet mit der concorde in
knapp dreieinhalb stunden von europa in
die usa katapultieren während sein chef
rtl boss dieter thoma in der economy
class eines ganz normalen fliegers
eingequetscht war was auch an seinem
übergewicht lag und etwa die doppelte
zeit diesen zustand ertragen musste und
das ticket von dieter lösche war auch
ein wenig teurer als das seines chefs
mehr als 20.000 dollar also rund 10.000
euro hat das damals gekostet
dieter lösche flug sodann auch mit super
zeit geschwindigkeit bei rtl groß die
concorde war einfach ein finanzielles
gesagt sei nicht nur für die passagiere
die entwicklung des passagier jetzt soll
irgendwas zwischen 2,4 und 6 8
milliarden dollar gekostet haben
british airways soll jedes jahr rund 40
millionen dollar verlust gemacht haben
der zivile überschallflugzeug einfach
nur eine katastrophe und endete auch mit
einer am 25 juli 2000 fing eine maschine
beim start in paris feuer und stürzte ab
alle insassen starben
zwar wurde die maschine noch mal
verbessert und startete wieder aber am
zehnten april 2003 war dann endgültig
schluss zu teuer zu unsicher und auch zu
laut viel zu laut seitdem können wir
noch mitunter scharf flugzeugen zwischen
europa und den usa hin und her jucken
doch das soll sich jetzt ändern es hat
sich sogar ein kleiner wettlauf darum
entwickelt wer als erster wieder in
rekordzeit zwischen den kontinenten
unterwegs ist jetzt wie nasa ihre pläne
dazu vorgestellt die weltraumagentur
plant den quiet supersonic transport
also den leiden überschall transport mit
ihrem explain herausragendes merkmal der
überschallknall soll viel leiser als bei
der concorde an dieser knall entsteht
wenn ein gegenstand schneller als der
schall fliegt und der ja allerdings
scheint die entwicklung nicht ganz glatt
zu laufen bisher ist nur von
windkanalversuchen die rede
dabei wird an dem projekt schon seit
jahren gearbeitet 2001 wurde mit der
entwicklung begonnen und jetzt ist man
immer noch beim
von moden ursprünglich sollten die über
schreibmaschinen schon 2014 fliegen und
letztes jahr sollte ausgeliefert werden
die website des ursprünglichen
auftraggebers ist nicht mehr erreichbar
alles etwas seltsam wie bei ihnen macht
könnte vielleicht auch hier wieder der
kleine david den wettlauf gegen den
großen goliath nasa gewinnen auch bei
spacex hat nicht die nasa
konkurrenzfähige ergebnis zement wege
sondern ein privatunternehmen beim
überflug heißt das unternehmen boden und
hat gerade 41 millionen dollar
eingesammelt um im wahrsten sinne des
wortes zu starten
2023 sollen die ersten überschalljets
des jungen start up abgeben und das
unternehmen spiel alle drei concorde
probleme gelöst haben der bodenwert soll
nicht mehr zu teuer zu unsicher und vor
allem auch nicht zu laut sein 30 prozent
leiser soll das flugzeug seien schon
2018 sein testflugzeug also ist es ja
ich will ein baby boom abheben lassen
uns von 2023 soll der linienbetrieb
aufgenommen werden und es soll billiger
werden nur 5000 euro soll dann der flug
zwischen paris und new york wechseln
wird durch flugzeuge sind schon von fünf
airlines bestellt die ersten seen sollen
an virgin atlantic dem
luftfahrtunternehmen von richard branson
gehen wird in atlantic wird sich auch an
den ersten test des flugzeugs p1
baby-boom beteiligen gibt noch weitere
unternehmen die sich an dem wettlauf
beteiligen us-flugzeugbauer boeing will
ein überschalljet für 23 passagiere
bauen der auf 2023 den flugbetrieb
aufnehmen soll
hamacher aerospace will ein jet mit 36
sitzen auf den markt bringen hier ist
der jungfernflug für 2025 plant
es ist also eine menge los auf dem markt
für über engagiert jetzt wenn es etwas
neues dazu gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich
hier drückt mir dafür hier einfach ein
abo aufs auge ist kostenlos und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke hier geht es
weiter mit dem hyper lob und den plänen
für deutschland wenn es euch
interessiert einfach draufklicken und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran